five
harrier lowell
and this is what got him called out last
time last time joey went for the while
standing three to get the big interrupt
the elbow dropped right in the middle of
the back
from under the bed the monster under the
bed
four
feet looking to close it out here good
back to avoid the throw rage mode now
doesn't finish evo man punish that that
was not a very good fight but that's
gonna be a combo you're gonna get the
wall too
bro that took off hell of damage
blue stuff both sides
three
okay
once again 18 seconds just about left on
the clock
life lead in favor of dante not by much
but it is there just about to ten break
on the one plus two throw eight seconds
left on the clock down back two joy
takes the lead and gets the tackle you
need this and something big breaks the
one plus two gets the support
up and this is gonna be oh my god that
was so
perfect the buzzer beater
0 is gonna be the count and dante takes
it two
no matter what down back to not dead
just yet blocks the low oh wow do it
again
do it again
do it again why did he do it again oh no
now it's a 50 50.
and tackles
what are you doing yeah you almost got
the blue
stuff
one
it's a lot of experience there to be had
oh no
no finishes the string this time
addison's been punishing it after the
second hit each time
or at least looking for third hit but
man right now junior
defense jumped out of it are you kidding
me um
this is not looking too good for annie
[Music]
[Music]
you